good morning John I'm in Seattle and if
you don't believe me there's a Space
Needle out the window come on camera why
does it just look white why is it up
there you go there you go there's a
Space Needle how you have to adjust to
me again but that took no time at all
strange camera do not understand G on my
last video there was somebody who's like
Hank you need to set your aperture
settings to different ones so that you
are less blurry when you move in and
away from the camera and I said oh I
shall do that and then I did try I
couldn't find the settings I am
currently on a tiny mini tour of the
Pacific Northwest with Paul and storm I
can talk to a camera and drive at the
same time which can be amusing Paul is
not driving which is a news business I
am NOT driving do you find me amusing
and mike phirman
excuse me of justin justin my nutsack
during the soundcheck for me which i
know now because i am a musician
professional you get up on stage and you
play the guitar and you sing a song and
I was singing I'm gonna kill you I'm
gonna kill you and your loud ass
frightens too and so they apparently
needed a lot of soundcheck usually it's
just like Duda did a sing sing sing sing
and it's over but they're pretty Pro at
the place we were at last night and when
I say last night I mean two nights ago
if you're watching this on Friday and
Jason Finn who is the drummer for the
presidents of the United States of
America which is a band that I totally
geeked out about when I was in high
school starts playing the drums - I'm
gonna kill you and I'm like oh god hey
don't screw up stay at the same tempo
please don't mess up he's playing along
just play just play and then Paul of
Paul and storm is like this is pretty
easy it's just the same three chords
over and over again he starts playing it
on the piano and I'm like okay
soundcheck is turned into dreams coming
true excellent so now it is Thursday I'm
doing this video today because this
Friday is another show day in Portland
Oregon are you from Portland Oregon are
you not going to be at my show that is
ridiculous
thanks for in the doobly-doo John I'll
be honest with you for a second I I'm
ashamed that I make money from
advertising because I believe that
advertising is a little bit evil it
feels that often advertising is there to
lie to us and make us do things that we
otherwise would not
not to see the thing all other things
about it I mean sometimes we should do
things that we don't want to do and
sometimes it's just about making this
spend money on one thing instead of
another thing yet I'm sure it's not all
evil I apologize to the people of
nerdfighteria but I'm not going to turn
off advertisements on these videos
because otherwise I could not make this
video and I believe that the good
entertainment of these videos is
outweighing whatever damage the
advertiser is doing to your brain and to
my brain of course I also see Geico
offering me up to fifteen percent or
more off on my car insurance up to
fifteen percent or more up to fifteen
percent or more you could not create a
more nonspecific statement and then
there's these new Toyota commercials I
believe that these are very evil in
which this ridiculous looking child is
making his dad feel guilty about having
an old car the kid is like I can't
believe I have to be seen and such an
ugly thing was that over-the-top was I
think that was over-the-top
the moral of the story of course being
you as a father should be ashamed for
being poor and or fiscally responsible
you know what Toyota eat it and I'm
pointing to a corndog it's it's just off
frame okay I'm feeling little bit better
now if you're seeing advertisements but
I'm making fun of advertisements too so
it's cool so I hope that you enjoyed
this video of me rambling on the floor
of a hotel I am in fact on the floor
here I am I'm on the floor hello people
of Portland I will see you on Friday
John I will see you on Monday